um we got time for one question you can
tell me how you lost your virginity
oh well momma's probably watching this
on to talk about that guy all right in
our house let's do some you lost you
lost your virginity in your mother's
house yeah so we're just gonna leave it
at that
so have fun cleaning one of these rooms
something special happened I stole some
of her we do she smokes oh really
yeah you ever been high with your mom
never well yeah like you weren't sure
yo is uh is that something you would
recommend yeah it's definitely you buy
want your mother very well after that
you know she call you and say I got five
on it not just asking for money all the
time are do you can you pay me back we
like come together now yeah that's 20
hard I got $30 go get a knife
oh my god I got a hundred I gotta go get
a half ounce like stuff like that
totally you got a you got a pool the
money with your mother so you can get a
bigger amount of that yeah we mean pass
to each other or green tea I don't know
why I'm having the best time cool bike
you everybody